so while doing in feminism in 2021  if you put a man in a room full of women  he is in heaven  and if you put a woman in a room full of  men  she is terrified she might be terrified  uh if the men in the room have huge  gaping holes in their ears like this guy  does so talk about projection and also  what the hell are you talking about when  you say that a man in a room full of  women is in heaven why what I have been  in rooms full of women many times in my  life and uh heaven  is not how I would describe the  experience this lesbian bar doesn't have  a fire exit I have never heard a guy say  hey bro I was chilling with my wife and  her friends all day yesterday it was it  was heaven we drank mimosas and talked  about pregnancy all day I was so in my  element man but this is what we find  feminists they exist in a world that is  not this one I don't know what world  they're living in but it's not the one  that I live in